es el momento de hablar de economía con
jorge hurtado aquí en directo américa y
tenemos la actualización noticiosa jorge
el país de argentina logró ya un acuerdo
con el fondo monetario internacional así
es y bueno el anuncio lo hizo el
presidente alberto fernández que se
mostró bastante entusiasmado con este
nuevo acuerdo luego de casi un año de
negociaciones argentinas anunció un
acuerdo con el fmi y aseguró que no
dispone de saltos de evaluatorios según
el presidente fernández este nuevo
acuerdo no restringen ilimitado
condiciona la seguridad social aunque no
brindó mayores detalles aseguró que este
nuevo acuerdo no los obliga a una
reforma laboral y tampoco impacta a los
servicios públicos o el gastos sociales
mencionó también que podrán acceder a
nuevos financiamientos y que pasará el
documento al congreso para su aprobación
angela el refinanciamiento consistía en
un crédito de 2018 por unos 44 mil 200
millones de dólares escuchemos parte del
discurso que digas hace unos momentos el
presidente de argentina alberto
fernández
este acuerdo no nos condiciona podremos
actuar ejerciendo nuestra soberanía y
llevar adelante nuestras políticas de
crecimiento desarrollo injusticia social
qué es un acuerdo basado en la confianza
del mundo en nuestras capacidades
tenemos que crecer para poder pagar de
otro modo no era posible y debemos
honrar nuestras obligaciones al mismo
tiempo que hacemos una argentina más
justa con más desarrollo con mejor
infraestructura
seguiremos también la senda de ordenar
las cuentas públicas sin condiciones
a nuestras políticas de justicia
sociales más aristas de la crisis jorge
porque hay datos del aumento de la
pobreza extrema en américa latina' así
es y bueno según un informe reciente de
la cepal en ese ámbito américa latina'
retrocedido aproximadamente casi 30 años
así lo indica el informe panorama social
de américa latina de la comisión
económica para américa latina y el
caribe cepal según este organismo luego
de dos años de pandemia la pobreza
extrema en latinoamérica se disparó
hasta alcanzar a 86 millones de personas
5 millones más que en 2020 y es la mayor
cifra en 27 años entre las causas el
organismo señala el fin de ayudas
sociales que pasaron de 89 mil millones
de dólares en 2020 a 45 mil 271 millones
el año pasado al tiempo que instaron a
tratar de mantener este tipo de ayuda
durante este año el informe angela
detalla que la tasa de pobreza extrema
creció del 13,1 por ciento al 13,8 por
ciento en 2021 aunque la pobreza
disminuyó del 33 por ciento al 32,1 por
ciento alcanzando a 201 millones de
latinoamérica
te comento argentina y perú
jon en donde la verdad es que hay una
situación que no hemos superado en el
mundo y tampoco en la región nuestra que
es de una emergencia sanitaria que hemos
que ya llevamos dos años de esta
pandemia digamos pero que estamos yendo
hacia una crisis social prolongada te
comentaba en el argentina colombia y
perú es donde ambos índice el de pobreza
y el de pobreza extrema crecieron 7
puntos porcentuales o más mientras que
brasil fue el único que mejoró otro dato
también que presenta este informe es la
desigualdad que aumentó entre 2019 y
2020 que verán de una tendencia
decreciente observada desde 2002 y que a
partir de 2010 había ido perdiendo ritmo
en forma progresiva muy bien jorge y
ahora vámonos para europa porque hay
datos de dos de las principales
economías al 7 francia-alemania bueno
mientras francia celebra un crecimiento
del producto interno bruto de
preocupación en alemania por un leve
retroceso en este último trimestre
empezamos con francia que registró el
mayor crecimiento anual desde hace 50
años con una subida del 7 por ciento de
su producto interno bruto según el
instituto nacional de estadísticas es
importante señalar que aunque la cifra
suene espectacular y muestra una sólida
de recuperación francia viene también de
una caída del 8% por la pandemia el
crecimiento fue de 0,7 puntos
porcentuales respecto al trimestre
anterior por su parte alemania la mayor
economía de europa se contrajo 0 7 %
puntos porcentuales en el cuarto
trimestre más de lo previsto por los
economistas y esto a causa del impacto
de la variante o micro allí el consumo
privado cayó significativamente
mientras que el gasto público aumentó el
año pasado alemania creció un 28 por
ciento y para este año se espera que
esto un 3 6% el ministro de economía
robert huff comentó que espera una
desaceleración hasta del 23 por ciento
para el 2023
y dicho esto pasamos a los indicadores
de la jornada comenzamos en asia las
acciones asiáticas se recuperaron del
anuncio de la reserva federal ayer sobre
los tipos de interés corea del sur y
lideró el repunte de las acciones de los
mercados emergentes de asia y en europa
las acciones cayeron arrastradas por los
valores del sector automovilístico y
cierta aversión al riesgo debido a las
tensiones geopolíticas en ucrania y para
el cierre con broche de oro por favor la
cifra del día bueno la cifra del día
tiene que ver con apple 123 mil 900
millones de dólares fueron las ventas de
apple en el trimestre fiscal un 11 por
ciento más del interanual el iphone fue
su producto más vendido porque muchas
gracias a ustedes y lo invito para que
nos quedemos con directo parís
[Música]